[Musik]
Reportage satanic panical
Redaktion
richtig stark was du da gemacht hast wie
der Wetter Donner er schreibt danke
vielmals Leonie du beeindruckst mich
sehr dein Mut wird hoffentlich
verhindern dass dies weiteren Frauen
passiert einfach nur Danke oder Nastja
schreibt unglaublich danke Leonie für
das teilen deine Geschichte und alles
Gute
wo beschrieben
ich kann deine Enthusiasmus diese
Missstände ans Licht zu bringen
nachvollziehen doch bei all deinem Eifer
geht die Empathie für Leonie verloren
und wie fühlt sich die Patientin
innerhalb dieser Reportage wird sie
ungewollt ein weiteres Mal vorgeführt
obwohl gut gemeint
ja also ich glaube das ist ja Kommentar
oder zum Teller kommt dass ich
instrumentalisiert wurde oder das ich
für euch benutzt wird oder manzwungen
werden
ganz klar sagen dass ich nicht so ich
habe das ganz klar von Anfang an das ist
mir ganz fest wichtig ist dass wenn es
möglich ist nie mehr Art muss therapiert
werden
das immer noch glaube dass Dir das
vielleicht erkennen was bei ihnen
passiert ist wenn sie mir Geschichten
das innerlich bewusst wird bei mir ist
das eigentlich glaube ich eine neue
Therapie oder Tableau die Diagnose
gegangen hätte mir auch angefangen
fragt was besseres passiert ist und
blüht eher ausgeführt haben
niemand hält man das wirklich Gefühl
aber ich nicht
Leonie heute gesund
nee also ich bin natürlich immer noch
psychisch krank dazu zu meiner
psychische Erkrankung ist einfach nur
die ganze Belastung
darf trotzdem selbstbestimmt leben also
es hat dir Vormund oder irgendetwas
entscheiden
krank aber ich habe vorher auch schon
Psychotherapie gehabt bevor ich zu der
Therapeutin bin aber allerdings ist das
ganze Thema von der rituellen Cloud ich
bin der Psychotherapie also vorher ist
das rituelle zurück
falsch die Erinnerungen waren doch
offenbar vorher schon da und Grund für
ihren Gang in die Therapie aber das ist
das narrativ auf dem ihr
Student herumhackt falls memory nee er
hat die Erinnerung
aber bevor ich dir Therapie bei Christus
rituelle Satanismus
Therapeutin Psychotherapie
und je mehr das über die Geschichte
erfahre was Satanismus und so ist was
ich angeblich Therapie umso mehr hat das
auch übernommen
von mir hätte das verzeiht und wenn das
natürlich über sieben Jahre hat zwei
Wochen eineinhalb Stunden therapieker
und in der Kliniken
übernimmt das und hör zu Tags aus dem
Kopf erinnere ist und was falsch aber
irgendwer hast das nimmt die
differenziere du glaubst mir wirklich
dass sie erinnern
obwohl es gar nicht passiert ist und
Sachen wo ich weiß dass sie nie passiert
sie fühlen sich für mehr gleich an wir
erinnern
über so lange Zeit immer wieder
verzauber
du welches halt einfach nicht weil
Diagnose ist sogenannte Dissoziative
Identitätsstörung das bedeutet dass du
in verschiedene Anteil abgespalten bist
und doch und dann Kommentar wo sie um
die discord und zwar von Maja sie
schreibt traurig diese Doku nun kann man
als Mensch mit einer dies ja nirgends
mehr hingehen da alle wieder ein faketen
keine Klinik mehr wo man hingehen kann
da die Diagnose nicht geglaubt wird
dabei ist sie im neuen icdf gut
beschrieben und kann behandelt werden
nur weil angeblich eine Patientin etwas
eingeredet wurde heißt das noch lange
nicht dass die Erinnerungen anderer
Menschen falsch sind
also ich hatte Diagnose und es ist
soweit eigentlich relativ klar dass er
dir weiterhin hat allerdings gesehen ist
Problem aber das die Diagnose im
Zusammenhang mit der
Satanismus
versteht Diagnose und zwar die Diagnose
steht eine völlig falsche Kontext es
gibt dies aber es geht aber auch dies
oder es geht aber vor allem dies wo
nicht mit irgendwem rituellen zügst du
hey aber jetzt seid ihr dies einfach so
der stampfen aufdrückt von Satanismus
und und rituellig Wald und so und damit
sie nicht Traumatherapie Diagnose ist
der wird Vorwerk abgebissen oder
und das muss aber rituelle missbruch 7
das ist Problem am ganzen Reportage
machen
zerstört hat aufgrund von Therapeutinnen
wo ich einfach falsch behandelt haben
und viele interessiert jetzt wie du
weiter machst und was das für Konsequenz
zum Beispiel wird juristisch vorgegangen
und wenn ja wie und wenn nein warum
nicht der Staat müsste da doch auch
Interesse haben dass du unterbinden und
den Bürger wenn er am schwächsten ist zu
schützen also
mit einer Arbeit vertropfen
einfach mal abklären was Hannah
überhaupt für Möglichkeiten es geht
verschiedene Wege es geht
die Therapeutin die Kliniken über
Schadensersatz es geht aber auch der Weg
über Schmerzensgeld zwei verschiedene
Sachen wo ich allerdings nur sehr
Schmerzensgeld ist nicht unbedingt das
wo nicht Arsch Treppe wo mich hat das
nicht in Geld gut machen das alles mit
darum dass juristisch oft schaffen dass
mich finanziellen entscheidend
genau also am ganzen Körper gefesselt
so lange können Sie direkt die Linke
schon so richtig ab Hunger gar nicht
bewegen eigentlich und die Rechte der
Verlängerung hat dass ich eine leise und
so Hanni oder das Foto aufgenommen aber
rein rechtlich darf man gar nicht mit
längerem auf die Art und schon gar nicht
mit dem Handy aber ehrlich
aber die hast du eigentlich überhaupt
und darum ist das Foto entstanden
aus der vorliegenden Akte das sind nicht
einfach behauptet dass sie die letzten
Wochen zwei Untersuchungsberichte publik
wurde eine zu der traumstation in Little
height und eine zum Psychiatriezentrum
Münsingen
festgestellt dass die Verschwörung in
Therapie geflosse
situations Verbesserungen
Problem dass die Verschwörung nicht
einfach so verschwindet sondern das
Winter mit dem Glaubens Hintergrund
therapiert wird und trotzdem ist es
wichtig sage dass Psychotherapie bis
ganz wichtiges und starkes
man dann Kommentar wo das Leben
vorgestellt hätte Sabrina hallo
was ich an der Doku gut finde ist das
Aufgezeichnet wird was Psychotherapie
anrichten kann ich glaube der allgemein
nicht dran beziehungsweise denke dass
die meisten Therapien eher schaden als
nützen ich bin selber sind über 20
Jahren Psychotherapie und profitiert
unglaublich stark davon es ist ja
Minderheit wo an satanistische rituelle
missbraucht und wo die Verschwörung
Therapie
flüstertherapie an sich in Frage sondern
die einfach auf eine Missstand haben
Kommentar was mir da machen was man
gegen die Verschwörung
unternimmt was die Staaten gemacht zum
Beispiel der Dave schreibt wir leben im
Jahr 2023 und es gibt Leute die glauben
an rituelles Teufelszeug kann das
wirklich nicht fassen wird dagegen etwas
Ernsthaftes von der Seite des Staates
unternommen Untersuchung von Polizei
oder ähnliches
Interpretation gemacht und im Bundesrat
fragt was er gegen die
verschwörungserzählungen in der
Psychotherapie und der Bundesrat das
Problem ist tatsächlich da und es gilt
ein null Toleranz für schwieriges
Erzählungen in der Psychotherapie
natürlich
arbeitsverantwortlich obliegt
normal zum Fabian Molina ist Bundeshaus
und Bundesrat
[Musik]
wie bist du zu dem ganzen Thema
Politik aktiv werden will wenn sich
Nummer die betroffene gewährten schien
sie offensichtlich nicht funktionieren
das heißt das Buch einmal
erklären
dass das falsch ist dass das äh sehr
viel Leid verursacht und das braucht
Maßnahmen
ja sehr wichtig
und ich bin einfach enttäuscht dass es
bis jetzt immer noch ja viel zu wenig
passiert ist sieht ihr das auch
aufdecken das kann da oder wir werden es
nicht verhindern
Spaghetti Monster und das ist auch
unsere liberale Demokratie an sich noch
nicht sondern das Problem es wird dann
zu einem Problem wenn lügt in ihrem
Machtposition und den Psychiater hättest
du wieder gemacht Position wenn man
lydin Machtposition hat wo so zügglauben
und dann auch
datenpositionen entfernen und das geht
nur über der Staat der Staat hat da
Verantwortung
verbindliche Sanktionen
zum Beispiel wegen mein control
Behandlungsfehler
aufgeflogen ist und sie nicht zulässig
verliert dass er nämlich abrechnen und
zwar Schweiz wird und da braucht der
harmonisiere bitte Kanton will
Verantwortung schlecht und sehr
uneinheitlich war
das ja die Psychotherapeutin ist oder ob
das jedem Land passiert
Psychotherapeut und plötzlich
landesliteratur verteilt und seitdem
bedroht von irgendwelchen
Zirkel da muss es doch ein Register
gehen wo man sicher ist dass die
Therapeut wo man sucht dass der gut ist
und das gibt sogar
offizielle Psychologie berufsregister
und jetzt sind wir da auf dem
offiziellen Psychologie berufsregister
von BAG und ganz Mal der Name
vor äußere
Therapeutin und siehe da ganz offiziell
ist sie da in dem
berufsregister Psychologie berufen und
da werden nur Psychologin und Psychologe
registriert wo über refundiert die
eidgenössische und anerkannte aus und
Weiterbildungen
zudem ist die Therapeutin auf dem FSP
und Psychologe Verband
mehr hat dem Verband geschrieben und
gesagt dass die mindestens ein
Therapeutin
haben geschrieben dass Ihnen keinsätze
gefallen kann
finde ich persönlicher Art wenn man also
betroffen ist
ich bin Kanton Mautern und Beschwerden
nie reagiert oder die verschiedenen
Situation oder das macht Frau das ist so
mich sauber in der Krise oder was
Situation wird mir beschuldigt sie nicht
eigentlich missbrauchzahl der kurvenzahl
dass sie sie missbraucht wurde vor
satanistische Zirkel also macht Frauen
ist dieses so ausgeprägt das wirklich
Schwierigkeit da ist das betroffene
und der braucht's unterstützt
unser beratet was hier die Möglichkeiten
wo aber neuroner Runde Tisch
organisieren mit Organisationen wie eine
Cash oder wie eine Klinik oder wie eine
Psychotherapeutin
Hollands skandinavischer Länder oder du
Saal 7 wirklich Schweizer Patientinnen
und Patienten
Position
muss faut die Kultur das ist Maude geht
und dass die eigentlich Qualität
es gibt fehltherapie wo auf Grundlage
von der
verschwörungserzählung passieren und
genau diese Flüsse in der Psychotherapie
und das ist das Problem nie wissen was
das für Therapeutin Reportage ansprechen
Lady black fragt aber warum wird der mit
der Therapeutin nicht veröffentlicht das
ist doch wichtig um die potenziellen
Opfer zu schützen mehr möchte auf
Missstand haben nicht auf einzelne
Personen zeigen zu dem Glauben mir dass
tatsächlich all die Therapeutinnen
wenn Sie das Ganze verarbeitet hat
es gibt ohne der Reportage
die rituelle Qualität
sehr wichtiges Thema und ein wichtiger
Aspekt von einem großen Ganzen ich finde
es einfach so schade dass die Doku so
einseitig ist rituelle Gewalt existiert
die Opfer haben es schwer genug gesehen
zu werden und dann wird Ihnen die
Glaubwürdigkeit quasi abgesprochen
bis zum heutigen Tag geht kein einzige
Beweis dass es im Untergrund
ihre Persönlichkeiten und programmiere
das ist
verschwörungserzählung und das erklären
Vorgänger
aber mit der Verschwörung nicht
existiert
wie zum Beispiel von der RA super Arbeit
genau darum ist die SRG und das SRF
wichtig danke und mir sage bitte und mit
Liebe zum Thema da falls du jetzt
Reportage